[Música]
ahí es donde te gusta Villas Jolie sería
cuenta un poco de el
inteligencia artificial
cuando en otros parece que este tema
de big data instalándose todo el tiempo
nosotros ellos revistas
la banda big data en tecnología la banda
big data en moda el amanecer en todos
los partidos
entonces esta gran pregunta de datos no es
este será el reflejo de la información en el
reflexión de datos todo el tiempo para usos
Después de eso, hablemos un poco sobre
estos usos nuestros teléfonos celulares nuestras casas
en todas partes estamos creando datos y
están almacenando los datos y, a veces,
enviando información todo si se juega en
diferentes gráficos y me siento como
información siempre hay un crecimiento para
celular que tenemos información antes pero
grande en ese momento y seguirá creciendo desde
big data es como ir de discotecas y volver a conectarse a
solo arena vuelve a conectar los datos de rutina y
polivalente no tiene mucha idea de ello
forma en que simplemente agarramos y contamos cabalgamos
en la arena no tiene uso final
lo interesante seria que tengo uno
si no quieres armar despues de agarrar esto
arena y eso fue tuyo en caxito da arena
este atraco y big data permiten que sea
obtener mucha información en
pensar en crear algo por sí mismo utiliza la gran
fecha como mkt dijo que era así en
caxito que con capacidad maxwell sm era
un castigo en tu lista no puede firmar
entonces ella usa inteligencia artificial
así que el ejercicio puede crear cosas
enorme para que puedas crear
características muy grandes es y
la inteligencia artificial es eso
habilita la pantalla montada en el poder del
La siguiente pregunta es si hay un
inteligencia artificial en inteligencia
artificial es crear sistemas que
parece
aprende es un video ahi funciona
la vida es buena no solo materias de las que se aprende
manera inteligente y aplicar eso y
parece que son como un humano ya lo es
puede entender que la inteligencia es un
ascensor y los tres deben estar pensando
este catálogo de brasil cómo lucir como un
ascensor es un dispositivo inteligente
lo que pasa en realidad es que si uno
dispositivo que no necesita en el área
el verano pasado humano te operó
era necesario era necesario una persona
porque íbamos subiendo al ascensor que
led no queremos ver cambios en
inflación tecnológica y si humanos y nosotros
otros no entendemos entonces es que ahí yo
asesorar con super concepto
interesante es que esta inteligencia
también dependiendo de la temporada por qué no
quiere tener 20 fue súper innovador
poner estos 50 años es supernova amores
hola es normal que quieras ejercitar esto para
nosotros otros aquí carteles de los ríos y
200 tapetes se sentirán y usarán en
tecnología de la misma manera que a veces
ni se les ocurre subirse a un aparato
inteligente llamado sensor que tomará
un lugar de jaca
ya que usamos edificios inteligentes
edificio inteligente nosotras nada
simplemente que el orden energía agua y
cosa si por la transparencia de
inteligencia artificial y está en todos
lados no es salud y ciencia ficción
del futuro aqui en el 2050 a ver
asi es en buenos aires ya tienen estos
cámaras que bloquean las leyes de patentes
los alto y a través de la lectura en el
dispositivo lanzar otras cosas hay un
cartel
sabes lo que esto es para ti
golpea una computadora y ella está siendo
otra interesante es no se si tu
están viendo un video erótico que sería
Le invité lana y un sistema de
vigilancia de tina para lo que está siendo
esta es mi historia en play csa irá allí
las patentes y también voltear la cara
inter y encerrar todo esto tanto es que
ningún compañero que pueda ser muy
peligroso o muy interesante
Yo uso lo que resultó ser otra cosa
que los demas cada dia somos
afectados son la inteligencia y
sistemas de recomendación año en que el
número en netflix película de netflix es
recomendado a otro en comparación con
ganar pero un mercado libre para
elogio de exportación otros productos tales como
caso de los productos que me asola
ya lo compre una vez y amazon nunca
nada mas me recomienda
obviamente ya no soy importante
como tiene que ser
o recomendaciones de los accionistas
sistema que compra o vende su
producto cuando es mejor o peor en 0
son usos que hoy se están transponiendo
los humanos no solo ellos y cual es el tiempo
están disponibles a través de
inteligencia artificial
google también dura hasta los que pretenden
No sé si hay interés en este momento.
hombre de negocios escribe google y completa
en un negocio que buscaría mantener una
poco miedo quien sabe y google eso ya
no sabía lo que estaba en mi cabeza
buena nota reconectando tanta informacion
sobre nuestros datos y que estamos en camino
que si un poco tambien tiene en la cabeza
hay una cosa que no existe tanto para atacar
en nuestros países a través de los estados unidos hay
muy fuerte si quieres un termómetro
inteligente
el termómetro inteligente que el acceso
no sólo mantener la temperatura de la casa a un
termostato a medida que aprende con el
mi jefe me sorprende por ejemplo
cualquier uqaila casas también integradas
y salvo trabajar en la mañana el termómetro
en la tierra
bien integrado durante todo el día con la casa
vacío simplemente entender ir
aprendiendo como patrocinador que ellos
de cuatro a cinco de la tarde y evitar que se enfríe
otra vez en la casa para llegar 6
cuando quiero volver ya esta en
reflectores de temperatura y edad y edad solamente
también seco que el medio ambiente
el grafico pedro silva tanto de
inteligencia artificial
tal vez ambas cosas en ellos en
nuestros periódicos y me gustó porque porque
el vuelo en la combinación interesante
el verano es importante este
industria por otro lado también el objetivo
mucha comercialización
esta primera foto es de un evento
llamado el sacerdote que es como el
otro calor en estos unidos
el dueño de la computadora la ganó por
mejor humano sin responder preguntas
de genérico a intenso en la secuela de la capital'
y pavo oh no se que la computadora
entonces me podrias responder mejor
obviamente es el fabricante de esta computadora
la derrota apunta al tiempo que todos me entiendan
¿Por qué tengo el mayor comprador en el
mundo pero recientemente es en 2016
google se las arregla para ganar uno
campeonato de uno pillado llamado go go y
zona ese tipo de r destino que son
compañeros super completos y se pudo
engañar esto es un error a través de la
la computadora fue y es un tremendo descanso
trajo un tremendo cambio de paradigma
porque si es robado no se puede programar
si realmente está allí, el fabricante de automóviles tiene
que tratar de eliminar es diferente de
diferentes formas de jugar para ver el
novia esto y esta aplicación el miedo lo hará
ser muy interesante
He estado hablando con los artistas de
kaka y sin señal en la compu a
diferentes estilos de pintura
se tomaron tantas fotos
fuentes de marco y luego de eso
plomo en la foto normal en la computadora ella
es un contador recreó una pintura usando el
estilo del pintor que ya esta muerto
estas son aplicaciones que obviamente estan
entre los medios y delata muchas cosas
interesante
te pareció entonces que estamos para
perder nuestro espacio no seas todo
otros vamos a la izquierda me gustó y el
las computadoras dominarán recordando que
nom porque la inteligencia artificial
necesita aprender no es sólo el
el aprendizaje de los párpados de pavo es
bastante aprendizaje por ejemplo
enseña cómo ser las líneas en el conjunto I
tengo un año
canberra ya apunta a un gato y un caballo y
en el sector del hierro porque aprendió que
estalló y luego nos llamó un gato es
esto no es un gato y todos los gatos y luego
con el tiempo ha ido mostrando gato perrô
por el gato bien jugado y termina
laboral
está en la cuenta de los algoritmos en
100 a 95 mil fotos de pelo de gato y
entonces no puedes identificarlo solo lo pongo
aqui solo que quien creo este sem
seguridad
¿somos los otros humanos otra forma de
hacer esto es con el proceso de adjudicación
castillo en el culo está justo ahí donde está
carrito tiene es llegar a esta marca y
no es posible llegar a esta marca
Synova primero al revés no se encendió
al revés y la única manera de que esto
pasar es cuando hay que aprenderlo y
ella aprende solo ahí porque para reconciliarse
supremo es cuando llegaron a la marca
todo este secom que ya ha sido aceptado por
humanos así demuestran el sistema de
La inteligencia artificial también es
como se puede ver kmsu naaaaa de fine
dónde se construyó esta altura y cómo pueden
ver es el feliz dueño de ese alto
se votó porque había una grúa que estaba
llegando y yo es mi esencia
de velocidad
entonces si el sistema de inteligencia
artificial que no es inteligente y
robando esa patente obviamente este ex
velocidad del traductor de google
traducido del ingles
tan turco porque el turco es un idioma
eso ni tiene masculino femenino no
existe y se va con una nintendo que
pasa es cuando intentan traerla
mineira y doctor zenon ellos doctor es
ingeniero google traductor acb o
trabajo empieza el contratiempo dijo el doctor
es el
cuando vuelves a google en ingles
traducir eso es doctor
el es medico y se cree el ingeniero que eres
sin embargo obtendrás que ya es mar un
doctor y ya tiene casi ninguno era para
que esto sucede porque nuestros textos en el
todo lo que usamos para enseñarles
las computadoras son enem y si seis goles
de genero y ok tenemos que pelear el ultimo
para que el futuro
los tres ya tenemos mejores sistemas
lo que representa una mejora en el área de
informática hay muy pocas monedas
false evitó todas las fichas como en
oportunidad de poner en si es necesario
ayuda a esta camiseta porque le dio a
entender esto para que no me sienta en el
la piel como un interés en las tecnologías puede
ayuda a esa cabeza
otro ejemplo es un algoritmo que es
algo similar que entiende la relación de
poder ser una obra se detiene y por lo mismo
mujer que muere es reinar
sin embargo, entienda que hay un
correlación entre tus piernas entonces si
sabía la misma pregunta que la sombra es
para la mujer programadora está cerca de
casa
si eres uno de los sistemas son
aprendizaje en nuestros textos en nuestro
textos suena sexista vamos a tener problemas y
como un amigo americano una vez al
el personaje es sexista un día la ceremonia
estará en la computadora que es sexista puede
vivir posiblemente eternamente nuevo
resolución de problemas
ronan y cuando amamos la inteligencia
artificial parece que vamos a tener un
batalla porque estamos aquí estaban
obsoleto y es uno que será verdad
dentro de algunos lugares por ejemplo
dentro de allí dentro de los centros de llamadas u os
carreiros dijo que sería la atención allí
atencion en un banco para pagar movil
entonces un chofer
estas son tareas que son muy
posible de celdas automáticas están en
jugadores
si hay un grado un alto grado de riesgo de
ser automatizado en el futuro
eso quiere decir que los demas no van
reunirse más a tiempo y el trabajo no es
eso es lo que eres, esa es la cantidad de esos
lugares que, por cierto, hasta repetitivos en el
la computadora puede ser mejor si el tango es
un sistema que puede salvar vidas o para
por lo menos evitar accidentes porque yo
Ojalá tuviera un trofeo de marrano alto entonces
es un área que obviamente es que en este
aunque el embargo esto es algo que ya
antes de ti ocurrió la revolución
industria, este tipo de
cristiana si en el 90 volvio de la onu en
automatización de plantas, fábricas y
tambien en la agricultura adolfo rio um
montón de automatización jones obviamente
sacar eso es obra de obras
manuales también que permite la ganancia de
economías de escala que tan pronto como el
los productos pueden ser más baratos
si en todos los demás para demostrar la
agricultura de forma convencional
parlamento en la zona suficiente dinero para
alimentar al mundo y lo que podemos hacer
es utilizar la inteligencia artificial para
sería mejor combinar lo que
en los demás como humanos somos mejores
con lo que nosotros el piloto con eso
la máquina puede ser bi de la aplicación llamada
el ex oasis un zoom en la aplicacion de portería
lo que dijo cst me encanta como es
tráfico y tenso y mejores formas de
desde el momento en que usan la aplicación
como esto
Estoy contando con una máquina que
creo que estoy entendiendo bien tu creencia
de una máquina y ser el mejor conductor
o al menos un motor más eficiente
a través de la aplicación de la máquina y no es
sólo eso
google ténéré o en la aplicación llamada
vaso que son mas botellas que tu
cargar un software dentro de este gato
entonces la zona está viendo un software loco
eso contra
y si estas usando
procesos de fabricacion solo tengo que encerar
mantenimiento de en la turbina del avión que
tiene un enorme manual de procedimientos para
como si accediera a mantenimiento lo que hay
segundo gol 10 jovey el paso a paso de
quien tiene cancer pero tiene la escena de los quehaceres
porque tengo esta cara de andar
libro para apuntar a agua y suecia con el que
es humano será mucho más eficiente
en lo que está siendo de frente debemos
irá a donde estamos protegidos de
inteligencia artificial y un sentido de
que podemos ser más humanos mejor
profesionales y mejores personas
lugares donde es más complejo
las cirugias no es que no habra
inteligencia artificial y me tengo que ir
en el horno dejar mucho en él
sin embargo, no regresarás 25 años
luana solo si existe ese conocimiento existe
padres del colegio y muy loco eso
tenemos una psicóloga que se fue en la camilla
no si tengo este problema de icomi
Me detuve a mitad de año con skype
asentarse bueno tobi va mejor
un día no te preocupes por la voz
anon computadora es mantenimiento
completar los enlaces completar procesos y
las reservas de mantenimiento son obviamente
oportunidades que solo existen en el ingenio
humano no puede ser
y obviamente informática y
administración de sistemas en
el necesitado es humano en cuarentena
máquina que la sierra es entonces acceso
el futuro de los demás dentro de ese
mundo de big data en inteligencia
artificial sigue avanzando y continúa
avanzando
podemos podemos podemos podemos seguir adelante y y
vicio en los demas y parece que no hay pelaje
al menos un día no hay evidencia de esto en 1
lo que todavía significa que 2111 1200 por
esto sucede entonces que podemos hacer
ahora estamos protegidos y damos un paso adelante y
subir esta clase positivamente a la
derecho tenemos que reconocer en lo que somos
recursos humanos y utilizarlos mejor en las competencias
explorando nuestra creatividad
nuestra individualidad a él en nuestro
el pensamiento abstracto es saber hacia donde vamos
estar mejorando nuestra capacidad y
Me asusté que ella era de
computación de inteligencia artificial
el dueño de otros humanos podemos
aportar pero es donde estamos mejor como
humanos
aquí es donde los tres tanques
está pensando que no competirá con
máquina tratando de ser más rápida para
no ser ser de intercambio
comprobar en un banco o la sierra siendo el
atención telefónica del centro de llamadas va
competir en la máquina de la intuición
en el corazón el daño es entender es otra
hermano quiero saber el otro lado y este
gran capacidad que no parecería
ninguna maquina puede retirar estaremos
mejores
la pandilla nos podemos apropiar pero esto
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
I